una sesión maratónica que inició el
martes y terminó en la mañana de este
miércoles con 64 votos a favor y 56 en
contra el gobierno israelí logró la
aprobación del presupuesto Estatal para
2023 y 2024 el Primer Ministro Benjamín
netanyahu celebró estamos sorprendiendo
en la economía estamos aprobando un
presupuesto responsable un presupuesto
que se mantiene dentro del marco un
presupuesto que recibe elogios también
de las agencias calificadoras tengo un
último mensaje para nuestros amigos de
la oposición no creen falsas
expectativas este gobierno cumplirá los
cuatro años de su mandato
mientras al interior del parlamento se
discutía la extensa lista de objeciones
de la oposición liderada por Yahir lapic
a las afueras distintos sectores
sociales protestaron en contra de la
medida
este presupuesto es en realidad una
culminación y el siguiente paso a la
Reforma corrupta en el sistema judicial
está enteramente dedicado a propósitos
que No servirán De nada para promover el
crecimiento y desarrollo de Israel en el
futuro
y es que de los 270 mil millones de
dólares del presupuesto al menos 4 mil
millones serán destinados en fondos para
partidos Ultra ortodoxos y procolonos
como los aumentos para que los hombres
ortodoxos estudien a tiempo completo en
seminarios religiosos en lugar de
trabajar o servir en el ejército así
como un aumento del 50% en las
inversiones a escuelas Ultra ortodoxas
que son ampliamente criticadas por no
enseñar a los estudiantes habilidades
como matemáticas e inglés necesarias
para el sector laboral moderno
[Música]